soldiers move in to secure the area
while swear
they check each classroom to ensure no
militia is lying in wait schools are on
the front line of this independence war
in Anglophone Cameroon and they're often
used as hideouts by the fighting groups
what most aren't useful is learning
anymore a whole generation of Cameroon
children are being denied an education
it's been disused for so long they've
actually got plants now growing inside
that's how long children haven't been
able to be taught at this school inside
soldiers check out what looks like a
store which they suspect may have been
used to hide weapons the last lesson in
English is still on the blackboard in
the Anglophone areas of mainly
french-speaking cameroon they've been
fighting to keep the British curriculum
installed by their former colonialists
but teachers and their children have
been swept up in an armed conflict which
is becoming evermore brutal what have
they exploded
a car roadside bombs are now being used
by those demanding separation from
French Cameroon the movement which began
as a plea for more autonomy led to the
declaration of their own country of
Amazonia with their own flag and has
morphed into what looks like turning
into a savage Civil War much of the
learner has been forced underground
studying is done furtively now like at
this secret school where they can barely
remember life before the insurgency do
you miss it
the separatists have banned education in
government schools and those flouting
their diktats face imprisonment torture
or death an age is no barrier the Army
says this seven year old was hacked to
death his school uniform enough to earn
his killing this head teacher paid with
his life for opening his school others
have been beheaded another who's been a
teacher all his life has given up after
his family was kidnapped and held for
ransom right now
I don't feel safe I'm scared I'm scared
if they don't find your money loitering
around the vicinity of the school you
are a target you had a key Mary not her
real name was also a teacher
she's now retraining as a tailor after
being hounded out of her home with her
two children are we waiting Kim yet
thought of you before you was like I
should just work on this
the way you know senior is not about 80%
of the schools here aren't operating and
tens of thousands of people have fled
the area we've been given special access
to the Camarillo military who say much
of the chaos is due to the separatists
you know someone can take in shoot even
in the air but the military have
responded to the independence movement
with heavy crackdowns and are accused of
burning down houses as well as schools
themselves to try to crush the
insurgency those fighting for separation
have their own anthem inside the former
British territory they're now calling
the country of Amba's onea and they want
Britain to sit up now and take notice
these was created by the United Kingdom
to transfer sovereignty to the people of
Amazonia it was created by the failure
of the United Nations to oversee the
implementation of its own resolutions
concerning coexistence with Cameron and
they have sat back quietly as hundreds
of thousands of our people have been
displaced internally some of move over
to Nigeria their actions at this
particular moment is too little almost
too late and the international
indifference means hundreds of thousands
of children are being denied an
education
Mary's eldest is one of them when was
the last time you went to school
did you used to like school yes what did
you like about it
is good there and then the future for
children living here looks grim and
right now few outside Cameroon know
about these atrocities or appear willing
to do anything about what's happening
here
Alex Crawford Sky News in the Anglophone
area of Cameroon